it with a cast of Doctor Who hi guys I'm
so thrilled that you're here because for
the first time in the franchise's 55
year history the thirteenth doctor is a
woman that accommodation I'm so excited
you take me back to the time when you
found out that you were cast as the
thirteenth doctor so I was told but you
were both there and it was incredibly
emotional because it's been a long
process of auditioning and you know
rightly so you get put through your
paces and if you're going in for a job
like this because it's hard and it's
full of energy and you kind of need to
be tested which I was and it was amazing
but I had to have this euphoria silently
because I wasn't allowed to tell anyone
for about three months which was great I
did tell my mom I didn't tell Chris and
Matt why was now the right time to have
the first female doctor well the world
was ready I think you know the show was
ready the world was ready the audience
already and we had a choice of a load of
amazing actors and then we got the
absolute perfect actors to play the part
so it was a no-brainer what is a doctor
without her companions how
a little tease as to who you're playing
and kind of whet their personality is
like I'm playing yes she's not as funny
as me was really happy with a job but I
guess she wanted more she asked for more
she got more she's going to hang out
with me to get magical best friend and
she goes on this a massive these amazing
adventures with the doctor and Towson's
connects Ryan and Bradley who is an ear
his character and they just create this
amazing bond Jodi can you describe your
take on the 13th doctor how would you
describe her if she spoilers again she
is she quickly is she seriously she was
sarcastic I would say you can help
because you watch the brushes but I
would say an energetic fizzing and
childlike it is delighted that's a good
word
delighted I've given you far thing about
playing this role is nothing is decided
within any person stepping into the
shoes of playing the doctor an answer
for me episodes episode seem to scene
it's making sure you playing the truth
of see and listening to what everyone
else is saying and then responding and
if that can be polar opposite to the
response you may be gave you know in the
episode of moment before and that's
what's fun about it there's no rules and
and everything is a discovery and so you
can I don't want to plan with that you
want to feel it in the moment and I
guess hang out
I'm curious to know do any of you have
yourself disclose it from this
conversation do any of you have a
favorite doctor who's been your favorite
[Applause]
watch a lot of great ones but I really
enjoy Matt's performance I'm curious to
know you know doctor who has such a
legacy so many people like once you've
watched your first doctor you'll
remember that person even as you
continue on do you feel like this is a
new time for new fans to jump in
absolutely I mean if there's one thing
you want to do is create a jumping on
point so that if you love if you love
the show you know the show this there's
plenty of stuff for you in Easter eggs
and all kinds of things if you don't you
can come in straight away you don't need
to know anything you don't need to know
any of mythology is we want we want
people who are fans of the show to grab
people who've never seen the show before
so come along you don't need this no
entry requirement you don't know
anything you see it's come another good
time I do love that so if if there was a
brand new fan who was joining it what is
maybe three things that they do need to
know before joining Doctor Who I did you
know
thanks America absolutely nothing at all
we'll take you through it yeah and also
food if you you know you create a little
Whovian and somebody then all these
series and episodes to to watch in their
own time you know it's not I think
that's the the kind of myth about the
show isn't it be if you haven't seen it
before you can't then join it and so
hopefully if we say it you know how does
it feel knowing that this time next year
if people could be cosplaying your
characters he's really moving you know
in the effort that everybody goes to I
mean my my friends just sent me a
picture and having fought with someone a
guy I just as the Little Mermaid and
it's just you know he's that costume it
would be you to be what you think wow
like this is what a place to come and
celebrate all the show well lastly I
know that everything is still shrouded
in mystery we don't even you won't even
let us know when we can expect it it's
just this fall which I'm alright but can
the same time is the UK in the u.s.
which is something yeah for the fans out
there right now what is the best tease
that you can give them
okay so well if we said every episode is
a standalone episode so if you do miss
the first step you can jump in it too
you can jump in a bar and then you'll
definitely want to watch it on playback
and go back to the beginning that's the
ticket in your movies yeah
and it's for every every family member
and that's that inclusive evening sat in
front of the TV which for me is quite
nostalgic so I really remember it and
that wanting to sit week-to-week
watching it you know everyone loves a
binge watch but it is really exciting
that this is gonna ever all the funds
are going to have to wait amazing well
thank you guys so much for joining me
I'm so excited the show let's wave bye
to the fans and we'll see you guys